[Music]  it's been an interesting election years  so far to say the least man that's the  understatement yeah and even though our  show it's not as political as some of  the other programs out there I think we  owe it to our viewers to at least cover  the big moments during the election  cycle now I'm told that there's a major  development happening right now let's go  to our election coverage  conan's 2016 election coverage  [Music]  hard-hitting stuff yeah now it's getting  tense hey what's that another major  development back to our election  coverage codons 2016 election coverage  [Music]  go to these 2016 elections Oh  no one goes as in-depth as we do it  certainly don't what's that you're  pretending to tell me something else  hey apparently there's more big election  news let's check it out  Conan's 2016 election coverage  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Goldie's 2016 election public when you  have to take off your helmet before you  fight that's pretty amazing  you